next week in Strasburg any peace debate
the biggest data leak in history better
ways to manage refugee flows and in the
aftermath that devastating attacks in
Brussels can terror is stopped
welcome to the agenda a little before
8:00 a.m. on the 22nd of March two
explosions ripped through the departures
terminal at the Brussels Airport an hour
later another at Malbec metro station 32
people died and many more were injured
and now supported the so-called Islamic
state are calling for further attacks in
Berlin Rome and London at the plenary
MEP is set to approve a further 10
million euros to reinforce staff at
airports new European counterterrorism
center and expect statements on the
attacks from the EU council and
Commission on Tuesday the Panama papers
are the biggest data leak in history and
have exposed how the rich and famous use
tax havens to hide their millions and in
some cases billions 2600 gigabytes of
data has implicated sitting presidents
prime ministers and celebrities after
protests calling for his resignation
Iceland's Prime Minister stepped aside
for an unspecified time Parliament has
been advocating better tax practices for
member states ever since and luck sneaks
how will they react find out on Tuesday
failing to cope with their numbers
Europe cut a deal with Turkey to send
migrants back from Greece but an other
means we sought within Europe to better
regulate migratory flows Parliament
wants a fairer central asylum procedure
this would overhaul the Dublin rules
estate their rival country of a refugee
will determine their asylum application
mep is also calling for a quota system
at per member state but cans to diktat
work the draft report revolted in the
chamber on Tuesday along with the
release of 100 million euros from the
2016 budget for emergency aid refugees
and now for the news in brief fuel
poverty affects 50 to 125 million people
in the EU MEP s or debate new plans to
ensure households have adequate
think on Wednesday MEP will vote to move
for resolution on the Zika virus
outbreak that likes to help member
states share information better and
assist affected countries and on
Wednesday the key debate was the MEP s
pour over the outcome of a to date you
council summit in March that signed off
on a deal with Turkey to end irregular
migration to Europe and finally on
Wednesday Portugal's president Marcelo
Rebelo de Souza will address the plenary
and as all we have its agenda take care
and enjoy the week